well I don't know how you were cheated
or what was cheated when we are cheated
there are many things a what were our
blind spots we have to be aware with
aware of what they are so that we can
prevent those things from happening B
was the person acting with malice or was
the person acting with selfishness you
know were they trying to hurt us or are
they just trying to gain for themselves
um
um were we taken advantage of where did
we contribute look the world is a cruel
place I hate to I hate to be cynical
about it
um and we can't go around not trusting
anybody because we're afraid that
someone's gonna you know lie to us or
cheat us
um because then we'd never build
relationships and so there's an
acceptable level of risk we have to we
have to take
um but if you were cheated
um
you can forgive but not forget kind of
thing which is you'd be like I forgive
you because you know it causes me more
pain to Harbor anger
um but I'm gonna move on and don't
expect anything from me in the future
you can absolutely do that